as the left shifts the Overton Window
cancel culture becomes more and more
demanding coronavirus continues to rage
across the country as president from
finally Don's mask and crime surges
while IOC blames you guessed it
capitalism I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like the government spying on you
then visit expressvpn com to stay
anonymous ok well I hope that you had a
safe and happy weekend we're gonna get
to all the news because there is plenty
of it we begin today with a simple
observation the push to the left is not
gonna stop if Joe Biden becomes
president I think there are a lot of
people who believe that Joe Biden
becoming president simply will let
everything get back to normal and once
Joe Biden is president and the polls
seem to reflect us and once Joe Biden is
president everybody can go back about
their business all the crazy stops
everybody calms down the left comes down
because Trump is no longer president and
the right comes down because Trump is no
longer president and slow old Joe just
as kind of there and everything goes
back to quasi normal I think that this
is really missing the boat I think the
reason this is missing the boat is
because we have had this pattern in
American politics for quite a while
where everybody misinterprets an
election victory as a mandate for their
particular program and to be fair this
is a bipartisan issue so in 2004 after
George W Bush won and he beat John Kerry
instead of interpreting that as I just
beat John Kerry he interpreted as well I
guess that my program is popular now so
I'm gonna move forward with Social
Security privatization and immigration
reform both of those things dead on
arrival and they died immediately and
within two years the entire Congress has
been lost right a twelve-year dominant
run for Republicans and Congress has
gone and the same thing happened for
Barack Obama in 2008 so after 2008 he
wins a sweeping victory over John McCain
and his first thought is you know what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do Obamacare and
the American girl like you didn't do
what now and in 2010 the Republicans
sweep back into power in the house two
years after Obama wins this sweeping
victory so if Joe Biden were to win a
sweeping victory in 2020 I don't think
that he would interpret that as oh I
guess people just really didn't like
Donald Trump instead he would interpret
that as well now it's time for my LBJ
FDR type program and here's the reality
the American people when they elect
people to government it's very rare that
they are endorsing wholesale all of the
big movement type changes that the
politicians think they are endorsing see
what's funny about this the politicians
deep down they know this deep down
politicians know that politics is
basically about personal appeal and how
you appear to voters they understand
that politics is very
rarely about policy they understand that
the policies they espouse are like
number four on the list of why people
generally vote for them people vote for
them because they feel comfortable with
them or because they feel that they're
going to maintain the status quo or
because maybe they're gonna trim around
the edges but most Americans generally
speaking are somewhere in the center of
politics right there people like me who
are out on the right and there are
people on the left and we are fighting
over sort of the ideological turf and
the people in the middle are kind of
like okay well if you swing too far out
there's gonna be a natural backlash and
that's why you've seen American politics
swinging wildly like a pendulum because
it's the politicians keep
misinterpreting the movement of the
pendulum as an endorsement of their
position instead of interpreting the
movement of the pendulum as just a
natural movement of the pendulum meaning
the pendulum swings okay but that the
pendulum swings does not mean that the
ball at the end of the pendulum or the
or the raiser at the end of the pendulum
is going to immediately stop in your
corner right it's going to swing back
because the pendulum really wants to go
to zero right the pendulum really wants
to stop down there at the center but
American politics doesn't allow anybody
to do that this is why if President
Trump had actually come into office and
then governed as a centrist which I
would have opposed he'd probably be
relatively popular today right if he had
pushed forward a giant infrastructure
package and if he had endorsed a bunch
of big government programs but if at the
same time
he had also scaled back some of the
regulations right that kind of stuff is
kind of popular which is what Bill
Clinton did during a second term which
is why he left off as popular despite
being impeached so my going inclination
here is that Joe Biden especially if he
wins a big sweeping victory which is
what the polls tend to see just is
what's going to happen at least right
now sometimes could change things could
be different we could come up with a
vaccine for coronavirus which would
change everything but barring some sort
of cataclysmic event from he's not on a
winning path here I mean that's just the
simple facts of matters to pull out
today showing Biden up in Texas I mean
if Biden wins Texas then basically he's
gonna win 40 states and you've got a
historic sized landslide like he
actually outperforms Barack Obama circa
2008 which is insane okay that is that
is a possibility at this point if that
happens I don't think Biden is going to
interpret that the way he should which
is I'm dead and people hate Trump right
which is the actual reason why people
would vote for Biden he will interpret
that as this is an endorsement of all
the liberal principles I've ever stood
for this is an endorsement of my entire
career because contrary to popular
opinion Joe Biden was one of the left
most senators in the United States
Senate for nearly his entire career has
heard of these outlier moments where he
supported things that were not wildly
left like the criminal reform and the
criminal justice reform bill in 1994 but
that is a rarity okay they usually his
very far to the left which is why he was
very much aligned with Barack Obama okay
what what does that mean well what does
that mean it means number one that if
Biden were to be elected in a landslide
I think the left would would declare
that this was the end of politics and
they would go for broke and by going for
broke they would actually push the
American public back against them in
other words you could have a situation
where Republicans lose the presidency
lose the Senate and two years later the
Republicans are back in Congress right
that is a very significant possibility
but the other problem is that with every
election and this is where the right
really misses the boat because the right
tends to focus in on politics I talked
about this and talking about this for
weeks
well the right tends to focus on in on
electoral politics they don't tend to
focus in on the cultural underpinnings
of politics and so the deck of the ship
keeps tilting to the left
it just keeps tilting to the left and so
even though the pendulum does swing back
and forth if the entire base of the
pendulum is sliding to the left that
means that the swing between right and
left is happening on a ground that is
not even it means that the entire move
of the United States is in the wrong
direction we're gonna get to this in
just one second why the debate matters
and why the shift of the debate really
really matters how the Overton Window is
shifting far to the left women get to
that in one moment first it is literally
never a bad idea to save money and this
has never been more true than right at
this very instant with all of the
volatility in the economy with nobody
knowing what's coming around the corner
with these kovat spikes like nobody
knows okay but one thing that you can
certainly do right now is do something
responsible for your family namely get
life insurance and save money while
doing it right these are two very
important things and what is kind of a
dangerous time and also a really
economically up and down time policy
genius has introduced another winning
combination an exclusive life insurance
policy with affordable rates and a
hassle-free application life insurance
is made of paper but this new policy
makes getting life insurance so easy
you'll actually enjoy a policy genius
compares a quote from top life insurance
companies in one place it takes just a
few minutes to compare quotes from those
top insurers and then find at your best
price you could say 1500 bucks or more
per year using policy genius to compare
life insurance policies so if you need
life insurance but you don't know where
to start get started at policy genius
com
the responsible thing to do and saving
money is super responsible so you're
doubly responsible you're like
responsible responsible you'll get the
right life insurance coverage and the
best shopping experience of winning
combo
policy genius it's nice to get it right
and again be responsible human being
make sure your family is taken care of
okay so the the shift in American
politics the the movement of the entire
base of the pendulum to the left is the
real worry here not whatever Joe Biden
tries to do in the next couple of years
because if Joe Biden is elected
president god forbid what he will try to
do probably he goes for a public option
in the Senate maybe he tries to break
the filibuster although I wonder I mean
I do wonder whether Joe Biden goes along
with that he's a Senate creature maybe
he does maybe he does if he does he's
making an awful mistake because the fact
is Republicans will eventually retake
the Senate and that will come back to
haunt him in exactly the same way that
getting rid of the judicial filibuster
ended up haunting Democrats and Donald
Trump became president but whatever
changes he makes over the next two years
I think the American public is gonna say
it's too much and they're gonna swing
back to the other side they're gonna say
listen we were reacting to Trump we
weren't reacting to we love you we were
reacting to we weren't that big on this
Trump guy if Biden is to win a sweeping
victory but that doesn't mean that the
ground can't shift so I'm not saying
what about this and no one should be
sanguine about this there's a piece by a
law professor named am not Akbar a law
professor who studies leftist social
movements and apparently teaches at
Moritz College of Law at Ohio State
University
this person has a piece called the left
is remaking of the world the professor
writes the uprisings in response to the
killing of George Floyd are far
different from anything that has come
before not just because they may be the
largest in our history or that seven
weeks in people are still in the streets
but also because for the last few years
organizers have been thinking boldly
they've been pushing demands from defund
the police to cancel rent to pass the
green new deal that would upend the
status quo and redistribute power from
elites to the working class
and now ordinary people are to social
movements have helped spread these
demands to a public mobilized by the
pandemic and the protests now on a
practical level am i afraid that defund
the police is gonna become like a
mainstream democratic talking point no I
don't think that's gonna happen but the
generalized anti police feeling is going
to be mainstreamed that is the goal of
many of these leftist movements is not
to achieve the policy outcome but to
shift the ground upon which we speak so
there's a general perception that police
are good people who are trying to take
care of you and your
family and your community that was the
generalized perception of police and
over the last few years we've seen that
image battered for some good reasons and
many many bad reasons right the videos
that come out obviously it's gonna
undermine your faith in police officers
but at the same time we have something
like literally tens to hundreds of
millions of interactions between police
and American citizens every year there
800,000 law enforcement agents in the
United States it turns out what the
polls show is that while people may
express distrust with police in general
when asked about their local police
they're very much in favor of their
local police the goal of some of these
movements is to D legitimize that to
make room for later on five ten years
down the line to make room for some of
the more radical policies what radicals
understand is that given time and given
and given energy they can accomplish
anything they need both they need the
time and they need the energy the energy
is now to shift the cultural debates
right get rid of all the cultural totems
of being Pro police get rid of paw
patrol right these things are all seem
very silly but in the end I'm not sure
they're so silly I think that's why the
left is fighting for them because if you
are fighting to get rid of all of the
cultural totems that remind you that the
police are the good guys well then it's
a lot easier ten years from now to say
yeah you don't think of the police all
that well do you well what if we just
got rid of them what if we just right
that's it that's a 10-year program it's
not something that's gonna happen in the
next six months right the idea of
canceling rent it's absurd no one is
gonna stand in favor of canceling rent
right now but if the idea is that
landlords are inevitably evil and
terrible and are trying to they're
trying to cheat you and they're very bad
people and then ten years from now
there's another economic collapse and
like you know what we're just gonna
seize property and nationalize it the
more you push the cultures have left the
more you are ceding the ground for the
future leftist crops to grow and this is
what this law professor understands this
professor says these movements are in
conversation with one another Krauss
endorsing demands they expand their
grassroots bases this is another it's
actually a good point
the defund the police group is a small
group the pass for the green new deal
group is a small group but then what
they do and you've seen this on college
campuses they unite forces against the
broader infrastructure it's not like
everybody in the defund the police group
gives a damn about the green new deal
and it's not like everybody in the green
new deal gives a damn about you found
the police but when you put them
together in opposition to X X being the
system well then you can sometimes forge
a coalition of power cancel the rent
campaigns have joined the call to defund
the police this month racial climate
economic justice organizations are
hosting a fort a crash course on
defunding the police
each demand demonstrates a new attitude
among leftist social movements they
don't want to reduce police violence or
sidestep our environmentally
unsustainable global supply chain or
create grace periods for late rents
these are the responses of reformers and
policy elites instead the people making
these demands want a new society there
it is and want to break from prisons and
the police from carbon and rent ok let's
just make a couple of points here if
these actually if you took that sentence
seriously you'd be talking about the end
of civilization right a break from
prisons and the police would mean the
purge it means all the criminals go free
a break from carbon means basically
every fuel that you use right now goes
away immediately a break from rent means
no one builds another unit ever right
they just stop there's no more real
estate development anywhere in the
United States and all the landlords man
in there buildings and then who takes
care of the buildings right this means
the collapse of civilization is what
they are calling for but they're open
about that right and want a new society
they want counselors in place of cops
housing for all a jobs guarantee which
really spells what we really want in the
end is government to take over all the
functions of the private market well get
rid of energy we'll get rid of police
we'll get rid of prisons we'll get rid
of rent and then we'll come in a big
friendly government to give you a hug
well many people find this naive polls
participation in protests and growing
membership and social movement
organizations show these demands are
drawing larger and larger parts of the
public sort of fundamental critique of
the status quo and a radical vision for
the future right this is this is correct
like this is written as a piece of fan
mail to this movement but the idea that
leftist movements are pushing the entire
discussion to the left that part is
correct and they're pushing Joe Biden to
and we're gonna get to that in just one
second this is the inherent danger of a
Joe Biden presidency not that Joe Biden
does anything radical right off the bat
if he does there will be a backlash not
that Joe Biden is going to be some sort
of world-changing candidate I don't
think he will be but the simple idea
that by electing Joe Biden you have
opened the door to the next step in the
social revolution and the Joe Biden not
only is not gonna shut that door he's
embracing bits and pieces of it for Moe
on a moment-to-moment basis and he's
embolden Ignace movement to move on to
the next step because remember this is a
progressive movement and when I say
progressive I don't mean like they're
making progress what I mean is that they
progress
/ step it is not the Russian Revolution
it is a soft revolution that happens
over the course of time and the left
understands this this is why they've
been pushing consistently for years I
use the example of same-sex marriage
because no matter what you think of
same-sex marriage it's an excellent
example of how a leftist movement
progressed from one idea to another
all the while suggesting that they had
basically reached the end point in their
crusade right originally it was we just
want the right for anybody to sleep with
whomever they want and that's none of
your business and most Americans like ok
sounds good and then there was like well
you know what we want civil unions so
that a gay couple doesn't a gay partner
isn't barred from the hospital if
they're if their partner is dying in the
hospital and most people like ok well
you could tell that with a contract or
you could just do a contract but I
suppose if you wanna make that the
default that you can form a civil union
and then you can do that you can well
property then sure go for it and this is
don't worry we definitely do not want
marriage and then people like okay well
civil unions sound good and they're like
wonder we want marriage because marriage
is exactly the same as a civil union
we're just changing the terms and we
deserve respect for our relationship and
actually most Americans eventually
started to be like well you know I'm not
comfortable with acquainting traditional
marriage and same-sex marriage but your
argument that it's not going to affect
my marriage and it doesn't really affect
my life okay okay and then it was well
actually now we're going to require your
business to subsidize same-sex marriage
even if you are a religious person we're
going to require you to make a cake for
the same-sex wedding and people like
hold up this started at you just wanted
people to be left alone and now it's
you're coming into my business and
demanding of me that I celebrate your
behavior right this is a pretty grand
shift that is the shift that happened
this is how the left changes the
conversation consistently in order to
push forward an agenda that would have
been unpalatable to most Americans when
the first agenda was put forward right
the gay rights movement begins in the
late 1960s it takes 50 years to get to
the point where you're demanding that
bakers be forced to bake cakes for your
same-sex wedding right that that is a
long process and again that's not an
argument against any elements of that
process although obviously I personal
arguments against same-sex marriage
being upheld on a traditional level on
the same level as traditional marriage
and I have serious problems with the
idea that anybody should be forced to do
anything in their business that they
don't want to do as a general matter but
the argument I'm making is really not
about same-sex marriage it's really
about looking at how when you keep
shifting the ground eventually the
policy follows you don't have to your
to shove the rock down the hill all you
have to do is increase the slope of the
hill that's all you have to do right
just keep it's like curling all you have
to do is is sweep away all of the
destroyed as' in front of the rock and
then it makes it easier for the rock to
sail in and that that's exactly what the
left is doing right now we're gonna get
two more of this in just a moment and
how Joe Biden he may not be the one
pushing the rock but he is certainly the
guy who is clearing all of the detritus
off the ice in preparation for the rock
to be put first curling metaphor in the
history of political radio we'll get
some more of this in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that you
have a broken car and you cannot go to
an auto body shop right now because
first of all you don't understand in
line second of all you don't want to be
overcharged and third of all the guy in
front of you is sneezing you should
instead check out rockauto.com it is
much easier than walking into the store
and to me and someone's demanding quick
answers to things like is your odyssey
in L X or an e X and then they usually
just have to order the part of mine
anyway and it's you turn in a card and
then they up charge you instead check
out rockauto.com rockauto.com
always offers the lowest price as
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear like
airlines do why would you want to spend
up to twice as much for it the same
apart like if you had to tell fie FG
1456 fuel pump assembly need for a 2005
to 2010 honda odyssey that'll cost you
like 3 or 54 bucks and a big chain store
it'll cost you at 217 bucks at
rockauto.com rockauto.com family
business serving Auto Parts customers
online for 20 years head on over to
rockauto.com shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers the
rockauto.com catalog unique remarkably
easy to navigate quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle choose
the brands specifications and prices
that you prefer go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck right Shapiro's in there
how did you hear about a spots so they
know that we sent you again go to Rock
Auto calm right now go check them out
ok so Joe Biden is the curling guy right
he's he's gonna be the the person who
sweeps away all of the little chips of
ice in precisely the correct pattern
said that leftist said the left is stone
hurled down the ice can land in the
target area Matt Weiser writing at the
Washington Post says Joe Biden is
looking at building 500 million solar
panels slashing US carbon emissions
within 15 years and rapidly expanding a
government-sponsored health care plan he
wants to overhaul the way policing is
conducted on American streets and the
way success is measured in primary
schools wait a second doesn't
sound like a very soft version of
everything that we just read about in
that piece one second ago right the the
overhauling the way policing is
conducted that is the soft corollary of
defund the police building 500 million
solar panels that is the soft coral area
of the green New Deal
slashing u.s. carbon emissions that is
the soft corollary of getting rid of
carbon right these are all soft
corollaries all he's doing is helping to
shift the ground and this is what
Democrats understand in a way
Republicans do not even Republicans in
power never try to shift the culture
instead what they attempt to do is shift
the politics right they'll shift the tax
rates or something right that will point
some good judges because the Republicans
still have a fundamental disconnect as
to what government has become an
American life government is not merely
the promulgator of policy government is
now the promulgator of morality this is
what the left is understood they've used
governments as the substitute for
religion and God and social institutions
and so whatever government approves
whatever government actors say this is
why most Americans look to the president
for leadership if you ask most Americans
at the beginning of the Republic they'd
be like that's weird like we need a
strong leader because otherwise the
country is gonna fall apart we need
George Washington but then basically I
mean when James Monroe was president no
one ran in opposition the federal
government was so weak that people were
like are we really like do we care there
were some hard-fought presidential
campaigns but the reality is that if you
ask most Americans between like let's
say Andrew Jackson and Abraham Lincoln's
name two of those presidents today you
probably couldn't by most Americans can
if you ask most Americans to name two
presidents between ulysses s grant and
Teddy Roosevelt they probably could not
right and I mean I'm not just speaking
of general American ignorance I'm
talking about the role of American
government in American life now most
Americans are like I need my president
to be a great moral leader I've never
thought you need a president to be a
great moral leader I'd prefer to be a
moral person but I don't think that you
need the President to be the he's not
the person you go to for great moral
advice or for a vision of the world but
because government has become so
powerful the the part of the presidency
that involves speaking about the nature
of American culture and America herself
has become more and more important and
the policy-making
end has become sort of the the trailing
after effect right the direction in
which we moved the country ends up he
the chief forward going factor and then
what follows is the policy this is why
for example the bleed over from Reagan
really reship ting the conversation
doesn't even happen during the Reagan
administration it happens when Bill
Clinton has to cut capital gains taxes
and when Bill Clinton has to put in
place welfare reform as the trailing
after effect of Reagan's reshipping the
idea of how government is supposed to
work in American life and what we are
seeing now is really the trailing after
effect of really Barack Obama and we're
gonna see that continued into Joe Biden
and if Joe Biden continues to forward
that you're going to see that continue
past Joe Biden which is why he calls
himself a transitional figure over the
past week according to the Washington
Post the presumptive Democratic nominee
has offered the biggest burst of policy
proposals since he effectively won the
nomination including a plan to spend
seven hundred billion on American
products and research it marks a
significant move to the left from where
Biden and his party were only recently
on everything from climate to guns to
health care and policing and flex a
fundamental shift in the political
landscape why well because number one
Biden thinks he's gonna win big and so
he can get very very progressive and
according to the Washington Post it's a
remarkable turn for a candidate who's
once defined by incremental ISM but is
now attempting to show voters how he'd
grapple with tens of thousands of
Americans dying from a global pandemic
and economy in tatters and a country
wracked by a reckoning over racism and
so he was moving far to the left and
he's doing so very quickly now again
that bears political danger for the
Democratic Party in the near term but it
does mean that everything is being
shoved to the left it also explains why
on the show I spent a lot of time
focusing on what I call the radical left
because I think the radical left becomes
the mainstream Democratic Party within
about five years basically it's just a
lead time to either stop the radical
left now or that is going to be the
mainstream Democratic that you're a
democratic party that you are fighting
with in the next five years to a decade
that is the basic rule whatever starts
on the radical left ends up in the
mainstream I mean this it really is
quite fascinating how this works they
sort of bleed over and so when we look
at the attempt to quash free speech for
example when we looked at the defund the
police movement we look at the canceled
culture and we realized that the
unofficial canceled culture which is
becoming more and more prevalent in
America eventually is gonna find its way
into the halls of democratic power and
then into government that's when things
start to get incredibly incredibly scary
because they're you're not just talking
about expanding the size and scope of
government you're talking about
encroachment on fundamental freedoms in
other words
don't think that simple social pressure
is going to be sufficient for people on
the left I think if people on the Left
had their way they would be encoding
hate speech laws in American law today
and I think within five to ten years
that will be the common common sense
position of the Democratic Party I think
within I think within two election
cycles you're going to see the
Democratic Party openly promulgating
directives at hate speech and hoping to
appoint enough justices to overturn the
First Amendment I think right now you'd
have the support of at least two I think
that Ginsburg and and probably Sotomayor
would support the idea of encroaching on
free speech on behalf of quote-unquote
hate speech I think that's fairly clear
and over the years I think that'll
become a more and more common position
in the Democratic Party we'll get some
more of this in just one second first
you know that I believe in individual
liberty I've been talking about
individual liberty and fundamental
freedoms and the attack on individual
liberty and fundamental freedoms our
founding fathers knew these were
cornerstones to a great civilization
which is why they created the Second
Amendment to protect all of those
fundamental freedoms owning a rifle is
an awesome responsibility building
rifles is no different that's why I love
the people over at Bravo company
manufacturing the people at Bravo
Company MFG support the right of
responsible private individuals to have
the access and ability to employ the
same tools as civilian law enforcement
as a means of defending ourselves our
loved ones our communities and our
freedoms should a threatening situation
ever arise BCM assumes when the rifle
leaves their shop it will be used in a
life-or-death situation this is not for
target shooting it's not for sport
the point of a gun is that you have to
have it work in case god forbid there's
someone breaking in the front door of
your home as an American you have the
luxury of living in a free society where
you can improve your life through
education and religious exploration the
open exchange of ideas you have rights
if and when your life and Liberty ever
come under fire firearms are first and
foremost a means to preserve the lives
and liberties of yourself and others
learn more about Bravo company
manufacturing head on over to Bravo
Company MFG dot-com where you can
discover more about their products
special offers upcoming news that's
Bravo Company MFG come again Bravo
Company MFG dot-com go check them out
right now Bravo Company MFG dot-com okay
so where is this cross rooms at the
cancel culture well this is the most
powerful cultural movement on the Left
right now is the cancel culture if you
say the wrong thing we are going to come
after you with everything we've got in
principles of freedom and justice
require that freedom and justice
themselves be put to the side so last
week
discussed a letter that was printed in
Harper's Weekly by a hundred and fifty
three left and sensor left
individuals old school liberals people
who disagree with me on politics but
also agree that freedom of speech is
pretty important and don't like canceled
culture very much we're talking about
people I think are just atrocious in
their politics people like no I'm
Chomsky but we're also talking about you
know people who are sort of old-school
classical liberals like Francis Fukuyama
they're they're a bunch of people on
that list hey well a counter came out
okay the the counter came out from a
bevy of canceled culture mavens who are
very upset very very upset that people
would speak out against canceled culture
and it's worth looking at their point of
view simply because number one a lot of
these people are in positions of power
and number two because this will be the
dominant position inside the Democratic
Party within five years this will be the
Party in five years now I will say it is
quite amusing this letter this response
letter is signed by a bunch of people
like some names that you would know many
people who you wouldn't necessarily know
many of the people who have signed
signed it unsigned so they say cancel
culture doesn't exist for a cancel
culture doesn't exist also I'm not gonna
sign my name to this letter because I'm
afraid that I will be cancelled or fired
alright so apparently cancel culture
does not exist except that they're
afraid of it anyway their letter says a
more specific letter on justice and open
debate they say the signatories to that
original letter many of them white
wealthy and endowed with massive
platforms argue they are afraid of being
silenced that so-called cancel culture
is out of control that they fear for
their jobs and free exchange of ideas
even as they speak from one of the most
prestigious magazines in the country
this is a very common argument is that
if you are concerned that there is a
group of people who trot around going
after your advertisers if you're on TV
or there's a group of people who will go
to your boss if they disagree with what
you say and if you are powerful if
you're in a powerful position but you're
afraid of what might happen well
obviously you're powerful right now so
why are you afraid of what might happen
hmm hmm and then after you've been
cancelled then they say well cancel
culture didn't really exist that was
just the voice of the people the letter
according to this this response letter
was spearheaded by Thomas Chatterton
Williams a black writer who believes
that racism at once persists and is also
capable of being transcended especially
at the interpersonal level since the
letter was published some commentators
have used Williams presence and the
presence of other non-white writers to
argue the letter presents a selection of
diverse voices but they missed the point
the irony of the piece is that nowhere
in it so the signatories mentioned how
marginalized voices have been silenced
for generations in journalism academia
and publishing so in other words we
should be able to cancel people because
we believe the system itself results in
injustice by the this is the the Robyn
D'Angelo view of racism again any system
that results in a balance of racial mix
we don't like at the end of it the
system is to blame and thus the system
must be torn down and if you are
complicit in the system you're a racist
and it doesn't matter if you're black
like Thomas Chatterton Williams the
content of the letter does not deal with
the problem of power who has it and who
does not Harper's is a prestigious
institution backed by money and
influence Harper's has decided to bestow
its platform not to marginalize people
but to people who already have large
followings and plenty of opportunities
to make their views heard so basically
you're you're simultaneously complaining
that these people are powerful and
therefore they shouldn't be able to
complain and you're complaining you
don't have enough power and then people
should give you power it seems like
mainly your viewpoint is a power
viewpoint it seems like your viewpoint
is driven by a desire for other people's
power that you have not yourself earned
as this entire letter is about how free
speech is really about power and how
truly the attempts you cancel speech the
attempt to crack down on people that
that is actually a force for good right
that that force for good is is making
the world a better place they say it is
impossible to see how signatories to
this letter are contributing to the most
vital causes of our time during this
moment of widespread reckoning with
oppressive social systems in other words
we disagree with you we don't like you
so they shouldn't have their letter in
Harper's Weekly also canceled culture
doesn't exist and it's good right so
this is the viewpoint increasingly of
groups on the left the good news about
that letter is at least now we have a
long list of people who believe cancel
culture is good but how does this
manifest in real life well it manifests
things like boycotting Goya Goya is this
major Latino owned company and now it's
subject of a online attempt to boycott
with NBC News cheering along the
progress right the NBC this is what the
media do again the media love these
boycotts because it creates a story
where there is none do you do you really
think that Oya is gonna lose enough of
its profit to sustain it for an hour the
answer is no there's no widespread
boycott of Goya it's not a thing every
time people say there's a widespread boy
it never really materializes it
materializes for like a day you can do
it to a small business right because if
you remove a week of income from a small
business it really hurts the small
business but if you remove like a
million bucks from the income of Goya I
just call that a rounding error anyway
NBC News says Goya's CEOs Trump's
comments lead Latinos to call for a
boycott that Goya was surprised says a
lot by Julio Ricardo for la jolla food
CEO Bob you knew might be regretting his
show his Rose Garden endorsement of a
president he called a blessed leader his
remarks at a Thursday White House event
where President Trump hosted a group of
Hispanic supporters came at a time when
us Latinos are facing a disproportionate
effects from kovat 19 and experiencing a
14.5 percent unemployment rate he
certainly struck a chord with Latinos
but not the one here at Trump's hoped
for instead his comments were met with
massive calls to boycott Goya the iconic
mostly East Coast Latino food brand that
has been both a staple and a nutritional
pariah for the country's largest
non-white population as Union News
comments so disconnected from the
reality of so many Latinos in America
sparked an outcry the question really is
why the head of one of the richest
Spanish American families would be
willing to risk his company's future by
siding with this president of all
presidents well maybe because he didn't
think he was risking his company's
future when he said something nice about
the sending President of the United
States maybe that maybe he didn't
realize that you guys were such
jackasses
maybe it's that simple but the boycott
of Goya is merely the first step right
the canceled culture is quite real the
attempt to boycott people based on the
great evil of a man said a nice thing
about the President of the United States
is utterly insane but it is quite real
it is not the only example these days
there are many examples these days and
it will lead to a predictable effect as
I say everything that begins in the
culture ends in the government when it
comes to the left everything that begins
in the culture ends in the government
that because there's a simple rule on
the left as my friend eric erickson has
said that if if something is tolerated
eventually it will be mandated according
to the left if something is to be
tolerated eventually the government will
make it mandatory that's it and
everything that is not tolerated
will be banned there there is no third
category called we disagree but we leave
you alone in the world of the left it
just doesn't exist like they're forced
to right now because of institutional
structures but that's why there's
they're thrashing up against the glass
of the institutional structures
trying to break out of that barrier in
one second we'll get to more of this and
then we'll get to D kovat updates and
everything else first let us talk about
a simple fact sleep may be difficult to
come by these days this is why you need
a helix sleep mattress so I have a
little baby my baby weight snip like
three times a night I have two other
children they also enjoy waking me up in
the middle of the night it's like a game
they tag-team this thing that means in
this in the slim moment between bouts of
restless anxiety I need to be on a
mattress that is going to put me to
sleep back up baby
helix sleep is the mattress that will do
this they have a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete matches your body
type and sleep preferences - the perfect
mattress for you whether you're a side
sleeper or a hot sleeper whether you
like a pleasure from bed with helix
there's no more confusion and no more
compromising helix sleep is rated the
number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine CNN called it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on just head on over to helix sleep comm
slash men take their 2 minutes sleep
quiz they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life I've got a 10 year
warranty you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up from you if you don't love it
but I promise you will really I mean we
love our helix sleep mattress get up to
200 bucks off at helix sleep comm slash
Ben that is helix sleep calm at /ban go
check them out right now helix sleep
dot-com slash Ben alrighty we're gonna
get you more on the castle culture and
then we'll get to your Ovid at 19
updates president Trump downing I'm
asking all of that first my new book how
to destroy America in three easy steps
it is on sale next Tuesday July 21st
long-awaited long sought after 6 p.m.
Eastern 3 p.m. Pacific we will be doing
a virtual live signing event the day of
release with your purchase of a signed
copy you can write in a question which
may be read and answered as I sign your
book live on the air it's a magical
experience you can pre-order your signed
copy and write in your question at daily
wire.com slash of n the book covers two
fundamentally different visions of
America that are currently on the table
one is the disintegration decision a
vision of America that says that
America's history is evil that America's
philosophy is evil and that America's
culture of Rights is actually just cover
for brutal power hierarchies sound kind
of relevant yeah because it is
everything that's going on right now
that is one vision of the culture that
is one vision of America
narratives like the Robyn D'Angelo white
fragility or the New York Times 16:19
project those are the disintegration as
people who wish to see the country come
apart to fray
and break or for 51% of the population
to simply dominate the other 49% of the
population then there's a unionist
vision of America that is a
traditionalist vision of America but
says America's history is flawed but
great it says that America's philosophy
is unparalleled in the annals of human
history that says that America's culture
of Rights is the fundamental framework
within which we should all operate right
you need to be a unionist not a
disintegration Asst the disintegrations
are using the canceled culture they're
deleting or silencing people they don't
like the book not only explicate s'
everything that is going on here and I
think a pretty thorough and deep fashion
it also lets you bunks it in a way that
you can use to argue with friends and
family and arm yourself against these
bad ideas how to destroy America in
three easy steps details how thatis
integrationist have gained so much
cultural ground so quickly and offers a
penetrating view of our culture at a
time in our history when it is
absolutely vital that you be familiar
with it again--that's daily wire comm @
/ been to order your signed copy today
and join my life signing on Tuesday July
21st if you're not already a daily where
I remember by the way should headin over
to daily wire comm and subscribe and get
the readers password three bucks a month
when you signed up 99 cents for the
first month you also get access to a
mobile app our articles had free access
to exclusive editorials like this one
from Michael Shellenberger on behalf of
environmentalists I apologize for the
climate scare so if you haven't checked
out the readers pass already head on
over to daily wire comm and sign up for
just $1 you're listening largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so one of the people who signed that
anti cancel cultural letter is now
they're trying to cancel them
so obviously cancel culture doesn't
exist the linguistic Society of America
is trying to come after Harvard linguist
Steven Pinker I've talked about Steven
Pinker on the show before apparently
because he said very very bad things 600
people signed a letter trying to kick
him off he distinguished a fellow's list
from the linguistic Society of America
what exactly did he do well he said for
example that data matters right he
actually declared the police don't shoot
blacks disproportionately they want to
kick him off the linguistic Society of
America for pointing out the police do
not see blacks disproportionately which
is a hundred percent true also Pinker is
blamed for referencing in 2017 New York
Times op-ed suggesting a way to reduce
the terrible toll of killings by police
Pinker tweeted police kill too many
people black and white focus on race
distracts from solving problems as we do
with plane crashes which again is like
obvious isn't it apparently that's very
bad it's like saying all lives matter
also Pinker is very bad because in his
2011 book the better angels of our
nature why violence has declined he
noted that in 1984 Bernie Goetz
a mild-mannered engineer became a folk
hero for shooting for young muggers in a
New York subway car apparently because
he said mild-mannered this was Pinker's
tendency to downplay very real violence
and so they attempted to get him kicked
off of the linguistic Society of America
now Pinker is pretty powerful and so he
didn't go down easily the LSA Executive
Committee issued a letter to Pinker
affirming the group is committed to
intellectual freedom but again the
assault simply does not stop and here's
the thing it's not going to stop in the
end until it becomes legislation and
that is the end goal there's a wild and
crimey knit the assault is so crazy the
canceled culture assault this is my
favorite example Penn State okay which
is a college where I spoke and there's
nearly a riot when I spoke there this
was back in 2016
I believe it was it got crazy Matt Bevin
it was wild like there were protesters
banging on the doors and trying to
disrupt police were insufficient it was
it was very crazy okay Penn State
liberal arts they put out a tweet that
said dear students each of you belongs
here and then it was a list of various
groups of students there are black
students our lives matter they're Muslim
and Jewish students your beliefs are
valued here they're conservative
students your viewpoints are important
ok
deleting it Italy did the tweet because
it said dear conservative students your
viewpoints are important but here's the
best example of where things are going
and I think that this is where things
are going and you may think this is okay
if you think this is okay and yeah I
would suggest that you really need to
reconsider the values you prioritize
okay so here's the story this is out of
Great Britain West Midlands Police have
arrested a twelve-year-old boy after
Crystal Palace winger
Wilfried Zaha received racist messages
on social media ahead of the club's
Premier League clash with aston via on
sunday Zaha 27 shared the obscene
messages on twitter before the match and
via said they would investigate the
incident with police after vias to a win
over Palace a police statement read we
were alerted to a series of racist
messages sent to a footballer today and
after looking into them and conducting
checks we have arrested a boy the 12
year old from Sola Hall has been taken
into custody Thanks to everyone who
raised it racism won't be tolerated and
won't be tolerated
before the match the palace manager Roy
Hodgson was asked about the incident and
told Sky Sports and is very saddening on
the day of a game that a player wakes up
to this cowardly in despicable abuse I
think it is right that wolf made people
aware of it I don't think it's something
you should have kept quiet about I think
it's very good that our club Aston Villa
and the Premier League are doing
everything they can to find out who this
despicable individual is and one can
only hope they will get identified and
they will get called to accounting they
will pay for these actions there is
literally no excuse there is no excuse
at all before kickoff both sets of
players took a knee to support the black
lives matter movement okay the kid who
was arrested is 12 12 years old for
sending hate tweets hey now hey tweets
are bad they're ugly they're yucky in
fact Twitter attempts to take down those
tweets right that's part of their policy
if you believe that twelve-year-old boys
should be arrested for sending nasty
racist tweets to adult soccer players
I've got some questions to you about
your priorities should somebody take the
kit aside and say you've done something
wrong of course
should that be how we normally have I
mean that's that's normally how we
handle things right as adults that's how
we handle things if we treated what's
amazing is if we treated each other like
people we actually like the world would
be a much more reasonable place if
somebody you knew and we're acquainted
with said something kind of nasty to you
wouldn't you take them assigned be like
you know dude that was really a terrible
thing to say and I would appreciate it
if you didn't say it again like that or
would you call the cops
using the cops as the great moral
arbiter the great Zeus thundering
lightning from the sky by firing
lightning at twelve-year-old boys if
that's the direction that we're gonna
move as a culture then that's a very bad
thing so I know they're people on the
left today they're saying listen we're
not calling for legislation there's a
difference between canceled culture and
government action I totally agree there
is a difference between canceled culture
and government action I just don't trust
you that you're going to limit this I
don't I don't trust it first of all I
think that your application of cancel
culture is a moral negative I think it
is ugly that you are attempting to
boycott a company because the head of
that company supports a political cause
you don't like bye-bye from tons of
companies I don't like right now on my
feet our Nike shoes that I bought a
couple of years ago I disagreed with the
political priorities of Nike I still
disagree with the political priorities
of Nike guess what I like their shoes
and I frankly don't care if the
political priorities of Nike and that
holds true about all of my corporate
purchases right I mean I'm working right
now on an Apple Computer right - I do I
agree with everything the Apple
leadership says about the world of
course not you think that I grew Tim
Cook on virtually anything of course not
but would that be a rationale for
boycotting an apple per se I think
pretty bad for the country when this
becomes the way that we do business is a
general rule this is what the canceled
culture wants but more than that I don't
think the canceled culture stops with
this I think the canceled culture goes
directly in the position toward the
position held by Canada or the UK that
free speech is not in absolute and the
free speech should instead be
essentially quashed by government I
think that we are moving very quickly
toward what just happened in in the UK
and that should scare the hell out of
anybody who believes that rights are a
fundamental thing and preexist
government to begin okay meanwhile on
the koban front we have seen this
extraordinary uptick in the number of
positive cases in states across the
country it is not merely happening in
Florida it has also happened in Texas it
has also happened in California it seems
to be largely dependent again on how
much time people are spending with air
conditioning from the reason I point
this out is because Colorado opened up
at the same time as Georgia Colorado has
seen a 41 percent decrease in day over
add a diagnosis of kovat 19 and that's
because right now the weather in
Colorado is pretty temperate so people
are outdoors a lot they're not spending
a lot of time in indoor spaces now in
Florida in Texas in California in
California is like 106 degrees yesterday
so people are spending time in
indoor spaces a lot my favorite thing by
the media by the way that my favorite
aspect of dishonesty by the media is
this new pitch for New York like visit
this I find really incredible
Jennifer Rubin had the incredible the
incredible gall to suggest that New York
handled this thing right I am not
kidding
she said New York City reports zero
covin 19 deaths for the first time since
pandemic hit this is what competent
government can accomplish the death rate
on all is Ron one down to zero like two
days after Admiral Tarkin ordered the
complete destruction of Alderaan no one
died two days after that cuz they're
already dead solder on no longer existed
okay guys the reason you haven't seen an
uptick in New York is because it killed
everyone okay
no 33,000 people in New York that is not
a great leadership moment by the way if
you actually take the chart of New York
what you will see in the chart of New
York's death is exactly be charged that
they told us we were supposed to avoid
all right if you look at you remember
the bend the curve chart remember that
the flatten the curve chart remember
that one
it had the very big tall bell curve and
said this one's bad cuz it's gonna
overwhelm the hospital system and then
it said and if you do this right than
what you will get is a is a less steep
curve same area under the curve okay
that less steep curve is looking a lot
more like texas or Florida or California
and it looks like New York New York
looks like the bad curve but we're being
told that now because it's amazing the
momentary thinking I'm Kovac 19 is truly
incredible and people were saying this
about Sweden well I could Sweden
Sweden's having a lot of death and I
kept saying guys you need to wait some
months you need to wait some months
right because Sweden is gonna go through
it and then on the other end there's not
gonna be a second wave because Sweden
will have already gone through it and
that's exactly what you're seeing you're
seeing rising caseload in Sweden and the
death toll continues to decline in
Sweden because it's already run through
the population you're seeing that in New
York as well okay but the but at the
time everybody's like a look at Sweden's
numbers today I was like no you gotta
wait and now when it comes to New York
they're like look at the numbers now you
should have short-term memory loss and
you should forget what happened two
months ago when it was completely over
running NYU Langone and say oh my god
you this is like I can't keep up with
the with the machination
that aren't committed in order to in
order to drive forward narrative about
democratic competence here
pretty incredible okay with all of that
said with that with the cases spiking
and with the death rate seeming to rise
in a lot of these states have been over
100 deaths in places like Florida and
Texas the last few days president from
finally put on a mask here is what that
sounded like
okay so president Trump is wearing the
mask looking as he likes to say like The
Lone Ranger so that's that's very
exciting stuff okay and again he should
have done this a while ago I think I
think that the the the the president
because he's a stubborn dude he he had a
moment there where he really could have
taken the leadership position on all of
this when he could have basically said
to the Democrats you guys are out there
saying that everybody should just be
able to protest as they see fit and
it'll just be fun and games and I'm
taking this thing real seriously instead
he kind of didn't he kept downplaying it
he kinda he wants it to go away and so
he wished a world where it had just gone
away kind of well now he finally put on
the mask this became a talking point for
the left meanwhile Anthony foul has been
sounding off suggesting that we might
need renewed lockdowns from time to time
saying that we definitely can't reopen
the schools the the by the way quick
note here again on a data-driven point
people keep saying that Florida had this
biggest single-day increase in positives
yesterday they had like 15,000 positive
cases the single biggest test day in
history yesterday
so the actual positivity rate in Florida
went down slightly over last week so
they're testing a lot more so that
increase in absolute number of tests
that one actually is due to the to the
increase in how many tests are done
right so the the increased number of
people who have it is not pure testing
but the increased identification of
people who have it is at least partly
testing rights now I'm not all testing
but it is partly testing and yesterday
is a good example of that
Louisiana continues to be savaged
Louisiana has a Democratic governor so
we don't talk about Louisiana but
Louisiana has the highest case rate per
capita in the nation at this point
Pittsburgh is experiencing a major surge
according to the New York Times again
Pittsburgh is in Pennsylvania
Pennsylvania is largely governed by
Democrats has a Democratic governor
therefore we're not supposed to talk
about Pittsburgh too much but big battle
has broken out over over Anthony pouchy
who's been a little bit sidelined here
according to the Washington Post for
months ouchies played a lead role in
America's coronavirus pandemic but as
the Trump administration is strayed from
the advice of many of its scientists and
public health experts the White House
has moved to sidelines pouchy
cuddling some of his plan TV appearances
and largely keeping him out of the Oval
Office for more than a month even its
coronavirus infection surge and large
swathes of the country in recent days
the 79 year old scientist and director
of the National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases
has found himself in the president's
crosshairs during a Fox News interview
Trump said pouch he's a nice man but
he's made a lot of mistakes when Greta
Van Susteren asked him last week about
pouches assessment the country was not
in a good place from said flatly I
disagree with him so this sort of
conflict is exactly ouchy is new
resistance hero because obviously even
though Trump basically made Falchi
famous right nobody knew how she's named
unless you're a real maven of this stuff
until the last six months or so now
Trump's the bad guy for attacking pouchy
and all of that now she has gotten his
message out he said as a country when
you compare us to other countries I
don't think he can say we're doing great
I mean we're just not a White House
official released a statement saying
several White House officials are
concerned about the number of times
dr. fowey has been wrong on things and
then included a lengthy list of the
scientists comments from earlier in the
outbreak and by the way this is not
unfair okay it really isn't yeah I know
that it's here's how you know it's not
unfair people will say Trump was totally
wrong about the masks in March like that
this has become the talking point so is
vouching like pointing out that
scientists have basically not had a
handle on this thing from the beginning
and continue to not have a handle on
this thing is not actually wrong I know
where you're supposed to basically say
that ouchy is is the godhead at this
point but as I pointed out I think he's
a man trying to do his best in a
situation where he has not a ton of
leverage and also a situation where
nobody really knows anything I mean the
most incredible thing about this virus
is that we are now four months into this
pandemic everybody's been partially
locked down it could go on forever
basically and nobody knows anything we
still don't know if kids are really
transmitting it we don't know if the
asymptomatic transmit it we don't know
whether it's fully airborne or whether
it is mostly droplets we we don't know
anything right that's the part that's
crazy and so foul Chi's opinion is as
good as yours maybe better than yours
but it's no better than John ioan itis
over at Stanford there's no reason that
that Scott Atlas knows tons less than
than dr. Apache about this stuff but if
you quote anybody who contradicts ouchy
ouchy because he's repeating points that
the left likes right now that we should
shut down schools and that and that we
are in a bad position and that bad
governance has been responsible for all
of this again other
trees are experiencing us back to Israel
had to shut down again Israel opened up
the schools there was a super spreader
event out of school and they had to shut
down again
Admiral sure are who is one of the White
House's top officials on this stuff he's
really heading me the response effort he
says listen now she's not a hundred
percent right I respect dr. Fauci a lot
but dr. foul he is not 100 percent right
and he also doesn't necessarily he
admits that have the whole national
interest in mind he looks at it from a
very narrow public health point of view
but let me just say there is absolutely
open discourse I feel absolutely free
saying anything to the vice president
within those rooms the vice president I
know briefs the president on a daily
basis so nobody feels like anything is
held back we all take this as a serious
crisis it's got to be science driving
the policy and that's the way it is you
know science is driving that it should
be driving the debate but politics is
obviously driving the debate how do you
know this because in all the
conversation for example about reopening
schools the there's it's become
incredibly political like I think
there's a good argument you made that
schools should open I think there's an
okay not fantastic argument to be made
that the schools should remain somewhat
closed I think I can hear these
arguments on any side I really don't see
them as political but you can see how
this is breaking down purely politically
because Trump says something and
immediately he's like a catalyst added
to some sort of bizarre concoction where
both of the elements in the cat in the
in a concoction I polarized because the
catalyst has been at it you've seen this
on on schools okay time for a quick
thing that I hate all righty so remember
how crime was not going to skyrocket
when we got rid of the cops remember
that that was funny that was really
super funny
I bring you the genius of AOC
okay so AOC was asked about why crime is
continuing to surge in places like New
York and it is continuing a surge so the
New York Post reports New York's plague
of gun crime continued this weekend with
15 people shot in the same number of
hours since midday on Saturday police
sources told the posts of 15 shootings
in 15 hours in New York City the
shootings including a 21 year old man
left fighting for his life after being
shot in the head while sitting in a car
in Sheepshead Bay early on Sunday were
more in one day than the whole of the
same week last year according to sources
they kept
43 shooting so far this week more than
triple last year's tally of 13 for the
same period I'd gone to bed early and
the next thing I knew I heard two pops
out my window they sounded just like
fireworks said a neighbor who identified
herself as Lucy of the Sheepshead Bay
shooting
I heard plenty of fireworks around here
a week ago I didn't think anything of it
until I heard someone screaming and then
there were police lights and ambulance
lights so there are tons and tons of
shootings over the weekend Commissioner
Dermot Shaye has blamed bail reform and
prisoner releases over the corona virus
pandemic for the alarming rising gun
crime which has brought increased
criticism for Mayor Bill DeBlasio
criminal justice experts say the cops
should focus on the flow of illegal guns
into the city instead of just playing at
the blame game so you're only you're
never supposed to blame the politicians
for cutting the cops
you're supposed to blame the cops for
not doing a better job policing while
you're cutting the cops
by the way crime is surging around the
country it is not just in New York City
according to The Wall Street Journal in
Milwaukee homicides are up 37 percent so
far this year on pace to break the
record of 167 in 1991 which included 16
murders by Jeffrey Dahmer homicides so
far this year in Chicago are ahead of
the pace in 2016 that was the city's
highest tally since 1996 in New York and
LA killings this year are up 23% and
11.6% in Kansas City Missouri they
recorded in 99 killings since January
far outpacing any record for the first
six months of the year community groups
acknowledged the crime increase but say
more aggressive policing to combat it
shouldn't come at the expense of
enacting broader reform oh is that is
that what's happening right now it is
not a shock that as you continue to
slash police budgets and signal to
criminals that they can basically get
away with it and then if a cop attempts
to defend a citizen that that cop may be
hauled up for arrest that's going to be
a bit of a problem city leaders and law
enforcement officials say the months
have locked down rising unemployment
more guns on the street and the fallout
from mass protests over the George Floyd
killing helped create conditions for
more violence at the same time law
enforcement officials say they are
weighing the risks of aggressively
enforcing the law concerned that a
backlash from activists protesters and
residents could trigger attacks on
police or replay of the riots and
looting that marked some of the earlier
protests in some cases officials say
police are backing away from some kinds
of petty crime arrests that give them a
higher profile on the street hoping to
quell tensions which of course is
exactly the wrong tactic it's exactly
the wrong tactic broken windows policing
which was utilize
in New York City in the aftermath of the
great crime wave beginning in the 60s
and stretching all the way to the early
1990s broken window policing was the
idea
you have to stop ignoring the people who
are jumping turnstiles you actually have
to start policing small level crime
because if you don't then people will
engage in larger scale crime police
departments all over the country have
decided they're no longer going to do
this and so naturally you're saying more
violence and that violence is becoming
politicized there's an awful awful case
out of an Indianapolis
according to the post-millennial a
24-year old named Jessica Doty was
fatally shot early on Sunday allegedly
following an argument with supporters of
black lives matter the victim's family
said the dispute was sparked by an
argument involving black lives matter
and language according to Fox 59 the two
sides parted ways before witnesses
claimed the perpetrator opened fire from
a bridge nearby and then ran away the
victim's father Robert J Doty told
Cassandra Fairbanks his daughter told
the black lives matter supporters that
quote all lives matter
he said apparently the victims fiance
Jose Ramirez said it was squashed they
went up the they went up the hill and
left we thought but they were sitting on
st. Clair waiting for us to come under
the bridge and that's when she got shot
she had a three-year-old son apparently
two people were shot in the same area
one week earlier including a 14 year old
that 14 year old died in what the
authorities it deems an attempted armed
robbery so good things happening all
across the country on crime thankfully
we have explanations complex
explanations for what's happening from
geniuses the likes of aoc allen general
Kashia Cortez obviously one of the very
freshest of the faces very fresh very
face here she was explaining the
representative from New York exactly why
people are shooting each other in mass
numbers in New York so why is this
uptick in crime happening well let's
think about it do we think this has to
do with the fact that there's record
unemployment in the United States right
now the fact that people are at a level
of economic desperation that we have not
seen since the Great Recession maybe
this has to do with the fact that people
aren't paying their rent and are scared
to pay their rent and so they go out and
they need to feed their child and they
don't have money so you maybe have to
they're put in a position where they
feel like they either need to shoplift
some bread or go hungry that night
um so shoplifting is not the problem
right now I'm just going to
that out larceny is actually down in New
York City shoplifting is not the actual
issue shooting people in minority areas
is not a response to I'm hungry like
that that's not the way this works it's
not okay I'm missing bread tonight like
listen I understand the argument that
poverty drives crime I do I get it but
let me tell you what poverty generally
does not have to drive murdering other
people who are impoverished that is not
correct
okay if you want to say that Jean
Valjean has to steal the wolf of bread
because he's hungry all right that's not
what you're seeing you've seen people
shoplift the TV because they're what
hungry for a TV you're seeing people
shoot each other in huge numbers in New
York City because why because of the
uptick in in kovat or something I'm
gonna go this is a pretty easy answer
you would throw the police from high
crime areas and the crime goes back up
very very easy but according to AOC it's
all because of bread lines it's all cuz
of bread people are shooting bread
they're not okay they're not and they're
not shooting the bread and they're not
stealing the bread that's not what's
going on here they're not going down
with local grocery store and just
picking up a bag of veggies and then
hold it up the counter clerk that's not
what's happening people are being shot
in mass numbers because you decided to
remove the police this is all genius
genius galaxies brain kind of stuff here
okay well you're talking about here is
just people who aren't acting like
criminals and I think it's fair to call
a person who shoots a child of thought I
think that's fair regardless of raise so
if you do that I have very little
sympathy for the idea that you were
doing this out of sheer desperation
because you lost your job I just I don't
think that that's the case I don't think
anybody goes and loses their job in the
United States then you know what I'm
gonna go shoot the thirteen-year-old on
the next block that seems like a big
miss there but again when your agenda is
to tear down the entire system then you
go with it I guess and you go with it
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of contents
otherwise we will see you here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel why douse key technical
producer austin stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by micro Romina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you want to cut through the madness of
our politics and culture and know what's
really going on head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we can all
bask in the simple joys of being right
see you there
[Music]